j'ai l'impression que c'est le millier
sur ce sujet de revenir un peu comme une
cousine de province avec mon petit
bagage et de venir vous répéter la même
chose de plfss on plfss
l'actualité de ces derniers jours me
conforte néanmoins fraude massive de 700
mille euros détecté de façon aléatoire
dans la caisse d'assurance maladie dû
haut rhin pour un pharmacien qui avait
falsifié des ordonnances modifications
de dates ajoute prescription création
des ordonnances
d'où l'urgence de la numérisation
d'ailleurs des ordonnances et puis hier
devant le tribunal de grenoble trois
prévenus comparaissaient pour un
préjudice de plus d'un million d'euros
un médecin et deux complices
comparaissait pour avoir falsifié des
dossiers des deux médicale d'état au
profit de 197 personnes domiciliées à
l'étranger et qui donc n'avait pas droit
à cette prestation de même ce matin le
figaro économie petits traits fraude
sociale l'assurance maladie enquête sur
une centaine de centres of time
aux techniques soulignant d'ailleurs le
rôle du lanceur d'alert charles frappe
que nous connaissons bien monsieur le
ministre pour ce sujet comme pour
beaucoup d'autres le proverbe populaire
quand on cherche on trouve trouve son
application
cette proposition de loi est le fruit
d'un long travail d'une certaine
obstination pour rendre ce sujet plus
visible mais aussi plus transparent je
le dis et je le répète notamment à mes
amis du groupe communiste républicain
citoyen et koffi il ne s'agit pas d'une
fraude de pauvres il ne s'agit pas non
plus de stigmatiser
étrangers il s'agit d'une fraude en
réseau organisé si bien organisé
d'ailleurs que tracfin la cellule de
renseignements financiers du ministère
de l'économie
sa tâche désormais dans ses rapports à
étudier les conséquences de cette fraude
sociale
le dernier rapport de tracfin est
d'ailleurs assez clair sur le sujet
fraude aux cotisations sociales 194
dossiers
voyez les crottes de cotisation ma chère
collègue gatti la fraude aux prestations
sociales 43 dossiers et depuis le 1er
janvier et ça c'est très important
un inspecteur du ressort du recouvrement
urssaf assure les fonctions d'agent de
liaison au sein de tracfin donc le texte
qui vous a été proposé initialement
comporter 24 articles
il résultait du passage au peigne fin du
rapport qu'avec ma collègue carole
grandjean à 100 à l'assemblée nationale
nous avions rendu à votre demande
monsieur le ministre et celle du premier
ministre edouard philippe
ainsi que du rapport de nos collègues de
l'assemblée nationale très largement
inspiré d'une autre d'ailleurs et enfin
du rapport de la cour des comptes
cette proposition a été
consciencieusement examiné par les
services du sénat que je remercie de
façon à éviter des mesures que des
mesures réglementaires ni figurer pour
assurer son orthodoxie parlementaire et
je suis un peu peiné d'entendre qu'ici
ou là elle ne serait pas abouti parce
que c'était quand même un long travail
donc je remercie le groupe de l'union
centriste à avoir inscrit cette
proposition dans cette niche
lors d'un entretien avec le rapporteur
général nous avons pu constater qu'un
certain nombre de dispositions faisait
doublon avec des mesures votées lors du
plfss
ou alors en cours d'examen par vos
services monsieur le ministre notamment
l'examen du dispositif pour améliorer le
rncps qui fait l'objet d'une
d'une expertise igas également la carte
vitale biométrique qui fait l'objet
désormais d'une expérimentation dans dix
départements ainsi un certain nombre de
ces mesures n'avaient pas figurer dans
cette proposition comme je voulais 10
soit elle faisait doublon soit elle
était en cours de réexamen par ailleurs
d'autres dispositions été écarté de
façon à concentrer l'attention du sénat
dans le temps évidemment de cette niche
et pour moi c'était un peu le choix de
sophie résultat d'une âpre négociation
avec le rapporteur
ce choix ne signifie pas monsieur le
ministre un renoncement ma part pour
défendre des mesures écartée dans le
cadre évidemment d'un autre d'un autre
texte
je maintiens par exemple que les
conditions ne sont pas encore remplies
loin de là pour éviter la fraude
documentaire
j'attends avec impatience l'évaluation
de l'application de l'article 13 du
plfss portant consultation systématique
par les organismes de sécurité sociale
du fichier à gèdre f je maintiens
également que la marge de progrès est
très importante je connais la position
de nos collègues du groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologique qui
oppose la fraude fiscale à la fraude
sociale
les deux fraudes aux finances publiques
sont à combattre de façon équivalente
encore une fois dans mon esprit comme
dans celui de carole grandjean pas de
stigmatisation
juste un constat et une alerte parallèle
et même équivalentes sur le non recours
parce que évidemment le non recours est
aussi un défaut de notre système à la
fois sa porosité pour les fraudes mais à
la fois le fait qu'il laisse un certain
nombre de gens à l'extérieur d'un
système alors que ces gens devraient
avoir droit à des prestations qu'ils ne
vont même pas cherché donc les deux
sujets sont équivalents il faut
combattre donc les les deux problèmes
avec la même énergie
je ne doute plus de la volonté du
gouvernement compte tenu de la feuille
de route monsieur le ministre que vous
avez eu l'occasion et l'opportunité et
l'obligeance de me
le communiqué la france est un pays
particulièrement généreux 750 milliards
de prestations versées avec un système
particulièrement complexe qui permet des
fraudes sans grande sophistication
compte tenu de l' échange systématique
de données et aussi du système
déclaratif le seul ministre sur ce sujet
il va vraiment falloir évoluer vers le
dit que nous une fois et vers un
meilleur et meilleures essences de
d'années je pense qu'on aura l'occasion
d'en parler
27 milliards de chômage partiel
plus de 200 millions de de fraudes c'est
ce qui c'est ce qui arrive en ce moment
là aussi il faut puisse contrôler ces
sujets un fraudeur au comptant est un
fraudeur qui revient faisons en sorte
monsieur le ministre qu'ils ne
reviennent plus il restera à presevo
services et les organismes pour que nous
puissions contrôler les dispositifs en
place
l'évaluation va être extrêmement
importante mais aussi chiffrés la fraude
c'est impossible que d'organisation en
organisation que même la cour des
comptes soit impossible de chiffrer et
moi monsieur le ministre je pense qu'une
des solutions serait probablement
d'externaliser le contrôle de la fraude
parce que lorsque l'organisme contre lui
même la fraude
je pense que à un moment on arrive à
l'aboutissement de l'exercice et qu'il
faudrait probablement externalisée 7,7
ce contrôle de la fraude des organismes
sociaux de façon à ce qu'il le fasse pas
même et puis j'en ai fini pour qu'on
gagne un peu de temps et puisque nous
sommes entre non je voudrais vous
demander quelque chose monsieur le
ministre
moi j'aimerais que le rapport que nous
avons fait avec carole grandjean soient
accessibles sur le site du ministère
parce que je trouve vraiment dommage
qu'un travail aussi excellent ne soit
réservé aux initiés
voilà je vous remercie de votre
attention nous attendons donc
aujourd'hui l'examen en séance de la
proposition de loi tendant à lutter
contre les fraudes sociales et je tiens
tout d'abord à féliciter et à saluer le
travail effectué par notre collègue
nathalie goulet auteurs du texte et le
travail effectué par le rapporteur jean
marie vanlerenberghe
non moi je suis aussi le voeu pour que
nous puissions à jour travailler à
l'avenir sur un texte qui viserait
lutter contre tout l'équipe de fraude
car chaque fraude est un coup de
poignard dans notre idéal
public 1 est symptomatique d'une société
qui se détournent progressivement de
l'intérêt collectif au profit d'intérêts
individuels la lutte contre les fraudes
sociales est un sujet qui revient de
manière récurrente sur les bancs de
cette assemblée pour ne citer que les
travaux récents nous pouvons évoquer la
proposition de résolution visant à
lutter contre la fraude transfrontalière
déposée par notre collègue andré
reichardt est votée par le sénat ou
encore la proposition de loi tend à
instituer une carte vitale biométrique
texte déposé par notre collègue philippe
millet et dont la présidente catherine
de roche a été rapporteur à noter
également qu'une commission d' enquête
relative à la lutte contre les fraudes
aux prestations sociales est présidé par
notre collègue député patrick hansen a
été mise en place à l'assemblée
nationale ces conclusions ont été
présentées en septembre dernier
enfin je rappellerai qu'une proposition
de loi visant à améliorer l'accès au
droit et lutter contre la fraude sociale
texte à l'initiative de notre ancien
collègue eric doligé et dont j'étais là
rapporteur avait été discutée en mai
2016 au sein de cet hémicycle
malheureusement l'examen de ce texte
avait été arrêté à l'issue du rejet de
l'article 1er faisant dire à ce texte ce
qui ne disait pas je fais donc le voeu
qu'une puissions cette fois allé au bout
de ce texte afin que senna envoie un
signal fort en matière de lutte contre
les fraudes sociales
à ce propos j'ai déposé plusieurs
amendements inspiré de mon rapport sur
la proposition de loi doligé visant à
compléter les différents dispositifs
présents dans la proposition de loi
discutée ce jour les chiffres en matière
de fraude sociale divergent et je ne
rentrerai pas dans ce débat car bien
malin celui qui peut se targuer de
pouvoir mesurer objectivement le montant
total de ce type de fraude
le rsa les aides au logement les
allocations familiales le minimum
vieillesse et arrêts maladie sont autant
de dispositifs concernés par ce
phénomène en augmentation permanente
quelques chiffres tout de même qu'ils
ont pu être vérifiées qui sont
symptomatiques des défaillances de notre
pays pour endiguer cette terrible
réalité près de 74 millions de personnes
bénéficiaires de prestations sociales
dans un pays qui compte 67 millions
d'habitants
plus de 250 porteurs de la carte vitale
qui ont plus de 120 ans et plus de 3
millions sont sans terre de quoi faire
pâlir le japon champion la longévité et
qui aurait pu
qui était jeune calment dont le record
tenait jusqu'à lors l'enquète sur la
fraude aux prestations sociales
réalisées par la cour des comptes à la
demande de la commission des affaires
sociales du sénat est présenté en
septembre 2020 permet de constater je
cite qu'il s'agit bien d'une atteinte au
principe de solidarité et d'un coût
financier élevé
le conseil constitutionnel a lui-même
reconnu à la lutte contre la fraude le
caractère d'une exigence
constitutionnelle et nounous trompez pas
il s'agit bien de lutter contre la
fraude organisée un an de la prochaine
élection présidentielle
il faut du courage politique monsieur le
ministre pour s'attaquer à ce problème
épineux et complexe j'espère que
l'exécutif est prêt à assumer ce courage
le nombreuses solutions existent et ne
demande qu'à être mise en place
ce ne serait que justice pour la
majorité de nos compatriotes silencieux
par pudeur et honnête par valeur ces
femmes et ces hommes qui chaque jour
font honneur à cette nation se demandant
ce qu'ils peuvent faire pour leur pays
et non l'averse reprenant ainsi un
célèbre concept keynésien je ne sais si
ce texte sera mis prochainement à
l'ordre du jour de l'assemblée nationale
mais il a le mérite de remettre sur la
table cette réalité qui n'est pas digne
de notre pays et qui est une offense au
père fondateur de la sécurité sociale et
aux personnalités politiques qui ont
oeuvré et oeuvrent encore chaque jour en
faveur de la solide solidarité nationale
pour que les plus faibles puissent être
accompagnés par la puissance publique
je vous remercie merci la parole est à
monsieur franck mais non ville nous
aurons des indépendants pour 4 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre madame la présidente de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
général mes chers collègues lutter
contre la fraude sociale s'est
assurément défendre notre modèle social
c'est pourquoi je salue l'initiative de
notre collègue et cette proposition de
loi portée par notre excellente collègue
nathalie goulet et le groupe de l'union
centriste
les enjeux financiers ils sont
importants nous devons veiller à
préserver notre modèle social auquel
nous sommes tous attachés dans cette
assemblée
le député pascal brindeau dans un récent
rapport estime en effet à 14 milliards
d'euros le montant total annuel de ces
pratiques qui sont d'ailleurs souvent le
fait de professionnels de la fraude
bien sûr ce ne sont que des estimations
et il ya là une véritable nécessité
d'objectiver ces chiffres car de
surcroît même la cour des comptes dans
son récent rapport présentait donc en
septembre dernier c'était si mais
incapable de chiffrer avec précision ces
fraudes pourtant tout indique que les
montants des fraudes aux prestations et
aux cotisations ont largement augmenté
ces dernières années
à titre d'exemple le montant de la
fraude aux organismes sociaux est estimé
par la cour des comptes à un milliard
d'euros en 2019 contre 850 millions
d'euros en 2010 est de plus en dénombre
près de 3 millions de bénéficiaires dit
fantôme de droits à l'assurance maladie
c'est absolument considérable la fraude
fait peser donc le doute sur
l'efficacité sur l'équité de notre
modèle social
il faut le constater aujourd'hui nos
organismes zone sociaux ne sont pas
assez armé pour lutter contre la fraude
tan dung tant des particuliers que des
professionnels
ainsi nous devons urgemment nous atteler
à repenser l'architecturé de nos bases
de données je pense notamment au
répertoire national commun de la
protection sociale
la principale difficulté réside dans le
fait que toutes les prestations fonds
versés sur une base déclarative avec un
contrôle a posteriori
il faut travailler au croisement des
données entre les organismes sociaux et
fiscaux
il faut aussi leur donner accès aux
historiques des montants versés afin
d'éviter les doublons les moyens
technologiques actuels doivent nous y
aider c'est dans cette même logique que
je soutiens le développement de la gamme
la carte biométrique
elle doit être totalement sécurisé et
d'ailleurs l'ex l'expérimentation
actuelle doit rapidement laissé la place
à sa généralisation
une telle mesure devrait permettre donc
de limiter le nombre de cartes en
circulation d'un autre pays
le surnombre de cartes en circulation
dans notre pays on les cimes aujourd'hui
donc à 2 millions de cartes
il s'agit de double détention ou de
double affiliation
il n'est donc pas acceptable dans un
pays aussi développé que le nôtre avec
un système aussi généreux que notre que
nous ne disposions pas de moyen de
contrôle plus performants pour conclure
mes chers collègues la pérennité mode à
notre modèle social dépend de notre
capacité à lutter contre ces fraudes
vous l'aurez compris donc le groupe les
indépendants soutient donc cette
proposition de loi qui va clairement
dans le bon sens il est temps d'agir il
en va de la crédibilité de l'état et la
puissance publique et de l'avenir de
notre modèle social
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant madame raymonde poncet mange
pour le groupe écologiste pour 4 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mais
chaque collègue la crise sanitaire qui
durent se transforme de plus en plus en
crise sociale et humanitaire partout
dans le monde
en france 10 millions de personnes
vivent désormais sous le seuil de
pauvreté
l'insee relève que la situation
financière des ménages s'est fortement
dégradée avec une perte de près de 3%
des revenus ce qui ne s'était pas
produit depuis 1949
par ailleurs près de sept cent mille
emplois ont disparu en 2020
majoritairement des emplois destination
des personnes en situation de précarité
et pourtant dans ce contexte alors que
la pauvreté s'étant tous d'un nouveau
public alors que 20% des ménages les
plus pauvres ont dû massivement
désépargner l'heure peu d'économies pour
faire face aux dépenses incompressibles
ce qui présage des faits sociaux
dramatique partiellement différé par cet
amortisseur et alors que les
associations nous enjoignent pour les
prévenir de lutter contre le non recours
aux droits sociaux et d'améliorer
l'accès aux droits notamment des plus
jeunes
les mesures urgentes dont nous débattons
aujourd'hui concerne la lutte contre la
fraude sociale
tout comme pour la réforme de
l'assurance-chômage du gouvernement
difficile d'être plus anachronique
difficile d'être plus décalé par rapport
à la situation sociale est plus
déséquilibrée puisque la fraude sociale
concerne coisy uniquement ici la fraude
aux prestations et que les fraudes au
recouvrement des cotisations sociales
par la plus conséquente estimée entre 7
et 9 milliards annuels par l'acoss en
1900 en 2019 pardon ne relève pas
apparemment de la même urgence et de la
même réponse
cela s'explique par la focalisation
constante relativement aux déficits
sociaux sur le seul côté des dépenses
sociales scrutés avec attention
alors que les manques à gagner des
recettes par la fraude ou les
optimisations de toutes sortes font
quasi ignoré alors que le solde
résulte bien des deux la lutte contre
les différentes fraudes et légitime je
tiens à le dire mais pas ce parti pris
le texte concentraient donc notre
attention sur la fraude aux prestations
y compris par des artic déjà satisfait
par le droit en vigueur
beaucoup d'articles visait à accroître
les moyens de contrôler mais surtout de
surveillance des bénéficiaires des aides
sociales au mépris du respect de leur
vie privée comme un soupçon de
resquilleurs potentiel par nature le
journal le monde documentaire récemment
la pression humiliante de
l'administration dans le quotidien des
personnes allocataires facteur de 10 de
stigmatisation cette stigmatisation
explique une partie importante du non
recours
c'est la partie immergée des droits
entre 30 et 40% des ayants droit ou rsa
et en 2018 entre 56 et 68% pour la cmu
complémentaire
l'ensemble des non recours au droit
étant chiffré à 13 milliards annuels
pourquoi ne pas dédier le croisement des
données à l'automatisation des droits
plutôt que d'envisager l'usagé qu'au
service du contrôle nul justification à
la surveillance des données internet
comme le propose la petite leucate ou à
donner des pouvoirs judiciaires aux
organismes de sécurité sociale comme le
suggère l'article 18 la priorité de
notre temps législatif doit être la
lutte contre la paupérisation en cours
et le renforcement de notre système des
deux sociale parce que c'est ce que la
crise que nous vivons requiert et nous
demandent en conséquence le groupe
écologie solidarité territoire votera
contre
merci la parole est maintenant monsieur
dominique théophile pour le groupe air
des pays pour quatre minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues
la proposition de loi de notre collègue
nathalie goulet entend s'attaquer à la
fraude sociale via une série de mesures
24 avant son examen en commission des
affaires sociales j'y reviendrai dans
quelques instants
ces dernières années des rapports et des
enquêtes ont permis de mieux comprendre
l'ampleur de la fraude sociale de notre
pays et d'y faire face plus efficacement
il ya bien sûr le rapport que vous avez
rédigé madame la sénatrice ce goulet
avec la députée carole grandjean en
octobre 2019 rapport à la suite duquel
un important travail de fiabilisation du
pack de cartes vitales a été menée au
sénat la lutte contre la fraude a été au
coeur des travaux de la commission des
affaires sociales en juin 2019
un rapport de notre collègue jean marie
vanlerenberghe sur les conséquences de
la fraude documentaire sur la fraude
sociale notait ainsi que près de 10 %
des dossiers des personnes nées à
l'étranger avaient été créés indûment en
septembre 2020 un rapport de la cour des
comptes révélé par ailleurs que le
préjudice subi ou éviter au titre
défauts avérés ou suspectés s'élevait en
2019 à 1 milliard d'euros ce sont près
de 290 millions pour l'assurance maladie
soit 1,8 fois plus qu'en 2010 face à ce
constat que peut faire le législateur
etc at il déjà fait des mesures visant à
lutter contre la fraude sociale ont été
récemment votée dans la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale de
je pense notamment à l'annulation
automatique du numéro de sécurité
sociale obtenue frauduleusement je pense
ce conditionnement des remboursements de
l'assurance maladie aux professionnels
de santé en leur inscription à l'ordre
dont ils dépendent
je pense encore aux déconventionnement
des professionnels de santé condamné à
plusieurs reprises aux fraudes
ces mesures qui pour certaines n'ont pas
encore produit leurs effets doivent
faciliter le travail des 4300 agents qui
oeuvrent quotidiennement au sein des
réseaux des caisses de sécurité sociale
c'est d'ailleurs dans cette optique que
le gouvernement a récemment créé une
mission interministérielle de
coordination anti fraude l'ami caf
la proposition de loi de notre collègue
nathalie goulet s'inscrit dans cet
esprit et propose d'aller plus loin et
plus vite si certaine mesure nous semble
intéressante c'est le cas notamment de
l'article 15 qui exige une copie en
couleurs du titre d'identité pour
l'inscription au répertoire national
d'identification des personnes physiques
d'autre nous paraissent en revanche
prématuré voire déjà satisfaite
c'est le cas notamment de l'article 10
qui entend sécuriser les données des
certificats de vie via des conventions
avec des organismes de retraite d'état
étrangers c'est également le cas de
l'article 21 dit insatisfait qui propose
de supprimer le conventionnement des
professionnels de santé en cas de
fraudes manifestes
mes chers collègues la lutte contre la
fraude sociale est évidemment une
priorité mais elle ne peut se faire que
par étapes afin d'assurer son efficacité
sa lisibilité
parce qu'ils en ont la charge si nous ne
sommes pas opposés à l'esprit de ce
texte
il nous semble donc préférable contenu
les différents éléments évoqués
d'attendre que les mesures adoptées aux
mises en oeuvre ces dernières années
fassent leurs preuves afin de ne pas à
mon avis ajoutez de la complexité à la
complexité
c'est pourquoi le groupe vers des pays
s'abstiendra sur ce texte
je tiens tout d'abord à saluer
l'opiniâtreté dont fait preuve notre
collègue nathalie goulet dans ce combat
contre la fraude
nous partageons d'ailleurs d'ailleurs
avec elle l'idée que la fraude remet en
cause le consentement à l'impôt piliers
de notre société
mais nous refusons de pointer les
bénéficiaires des prestations sociales
comme les principaux frondeurs tout en
nombre qu'en montant les allocations
familiales représentent une part
minoritaire des fraudes qualifier
surtout ces fraudes sont pour 70% des
omissions bien sûr nous n'acceptons
aucune fraude
je le dis à natal et à notre collègue
nathalie goulet
mais nous disons seulement que ce texte
s'attaque à la minorité du montant de la
fraude qui est déjà contrôlée tandis que
la majorité du montant de la fraude
demeure libre et impunies pour nous les
vrais frondeurs ce sont les quinze mille
français ou entreprises tricolores qui
sont établies au luxembourg et qui
soustrait à l'impôt 6500 milliards
d'euros les fraudeurs ce sont les 166
filiales d'entreprises du cac 40 qui
détiennent des avoirs au luxembourg
ce sont les 80 milliards d'euros de
fraude fiscale et donc de perte de
recettes pour le budget de l'état
les fraudeurs se sont aussi les patrons
qui ne cotisent pas à la sécurité
sociale et font perdre 8 milliards
d'euros chaque année à l'hôpital et à
notre régime de retraite
malheureusement cette proposition de loi
ne s'attaque absolument pas à cette
fraude
vous préférez donc pointé du doigt la
fraude aux prestations sociales
nous pensons que ça stigmatise les
pauvres vous pointez du doigt les petits
tricheurs qui cache les grands voleurs
cette fraude aux prestations sociales
chiffré par la cour des comptes un goal
2 milliards d'euros soit en comparaison
des 450 milliards d'euros de prestations
versées par la sécurité sociale
moins de 0,3 pour cent du total
concernant la fraude documentaire elle
serait située entre 117 millions et 138
millions d'euros bien loin des 14
milliards d'euros évoqué par certains
contrairement aux idées reçues en 2019
les frondeurs ne sont pas celles et ceux
que l'on croit ainsi la fraude à
l'assurance maladie provient dans
seulement 21% des cas des salariés les
salariés les employeurs à linverse dans
31% des établissements de santé et
médico-sociaux et dans 48 % des
professionnels de santé
en comparaison le non recours aux
prestations sociales atteint un montant
largement supérieur à la fraude aux
prestations sociales
ainsi le non recours pour le revenu de
solidarité active
et de 36% soit plus de 3 6 milliards
d'euros
le non-recours polar pour la couverture
maladie universelle et de 34% et enfin
le non recours pour l'aide à la
complémentaire santé de 70% dans le pas
de calais nous avons des familles qui
survivent sous les radars et renoncent à
leurs droits car elle refuse d'être
stigmatisés comme des assistés nos
concitoyens renoncent à leurs droits par
méconnaissance et parce que ils sont
montrés du doigt
cette proposition de loi les stigmatise
elle stigmatise nous pensons donc le
plus pauvre au lieu de s'attaquer aux
riches et aux puissants véritable
fraudeurs professionnels pour toutes ces
raisons le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen et écologistes votera contre
cette proposition de loi
je vous remercie merci la parole est
maintenant madame nadia sollogoub pour
le groupe union centriste pour six
minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues notre
collègue nathalie goulet
dans le prolongement des travaux qu'elle
mène depuis de longues années et forte
de son expertise en la matière nous
propose aujourd'hui de légiférer afin
d'appliquer les mesures urgentes de
lutte contre la fraude sociale
le champ de la fraude est si vaste si
complexe si habile a évolué et qu'il est
délicat de choisir les outils les plus
efficaces les plus pertinents les plus
opérationnels c'est ainsi que son texte
initial volontairement limité au chant
de la fraude sociale a été recentré par
la commission sur proposition du
rapporteur sur quelques sujets cible qui
vont permettre au parlement d'émettre un
signal fort en effet la fraude en
général est par essence insupportable et
inadmissible
nous ne pouvons la tolérer lutter contre
les fraudes
c'est défendre notre contrat social s'il
subsiste des incertitudes sur le volume
financier réel
la fraude une chose est certaine c'est
que les sommes non collectés ou
distribuer à tort ne pourront plus être
affectées directement ou indirectement à
la politique sociale le système français
de sécurité sociale se caractérise par
sa diversité et son extrême complexité
dans la délivrance des prestations
sociales
il fonctionne par traitement de masse et
dématérialisation de l'information
il doit désormais faire face à des
populations qui ne sont plus attachés
strictement un territoire tout cela
ouvre hélas une large porte à des
réseaux de fraude au système très
organisé les fraudes sociales touche à
l'identité la composition familiale les
liens de parenté le décès la nationalité
la résidence l'état de santé et le
niveau de revenu elle se caractérise par
l' obtention indue de droits à
l'assurance-maladie à l'aide médicale
d'état à des prescriptions à des cumuls
de prestations etc etc alors que les
systèmes de fraude évolué avec une
agilité déconcertante la réglementation
et la loi doivent avec la même agilité
la même rapidité produire les parades
adapter la police vont aller aussi vite
que les voleurs nous disait il ya peu
gérald darmanin et bien dans ce domaine
également si bien qu'au delà de ce texte
étudient en ce 11 mars 2021
nous devons nous préparer je le crois
sincèrement mes chers collègues à
remettre sans cesse sur le métier cet
ouvrage et ne retrouver aussi souvent
qu'il le faudra pour voter de nouvelles
mesures urgentes de lutte contre la
fraude sociale et nous le ferons parce
que frauder c'est voler le rapport de la
cour des comptes de septembre 2020
s'intitule la lutte contre les fraudes
aux prestations sociales des progrès
trop lents
un changement d'échelle indispensables
et bien si un message doit passer
aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues c'est qu'il est fini le
temps des fraudes aux sceptiques le
temps où le sujet était pudiquement
glissé sous le tapis
il faut désormais prendre le problème à
bras le corps s'en saisir et ne plus
jamais détourner le regard
cela pèse certainement par des moyens en
matériel et en personnel indispensable
les derniers pays
et plfss marque de première avancée mais
nathalie goulet nous pose la question
comment mieux faire
je vous remercie sincèrement monsieur
ministre de nous avoir apporté
aujourd'hui plusieurs perspectives via
un plan d'action volontariste
j'insiste sur le fait que dans la mesure
où tout document peut-être falsifiés et
sachant que la faux documentaire est la
mère de toutes les fraudes
alors il ya ni qu'il était absolue à
pouvoir disposer de documents
d'identification en couleur et de
qualité correcte
de même le principe des prestations
fondées sur un système déclaratif tels
que les apl est trop fragile et il faut
se donner comme proposé à l'article 8 la
possibilité de l'échangé de données à
des fans contrôle quant aux retraites
versées à l'étranger afin de mettre fin
des dérives connues et scandaleuse il
faut sécuriser les données de certificat
de vie en utilisant des données
biométriques et en conventionnement avec
les organismes de retraite d'état
étrangers
les chants des fraude transfrontalière
s'ouvre également et on ne peut que s'en
féliciter
merci monsieur le ministre pour conclure
mon intervention je me permets une
petite remarque marginal comment
accepter que le citoyen lambda comme moi
pas comme vous mais comme moi doivent à
chaque instant produire des montagnes de
documents administratifs dont l'idée
l'utilité peut parfois sembler
contestable alors je donne un petit
exemple on parlait récemment de médecins
retraités qui pourrait être indemnité de
leur prestation dans les centres de
vaccination qu'ovide doivent produire un
dossier extrêmement complet avec extrait
kbis casier judiciaire déclaration de
situation matrimoniale et parallèlement
à cela grâce à tout cela des malfrats
sans scrupules se glisse dans cette
déferlante documentaire et ils font
fortune au détriment des honnêtes
contributeurs alors vous aurez compris
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
l'union centriste votera ce texte ainsi
recentré jour merci merci
monsieur le ministre je vous en prie
merci monsieur le président quelques
mois en réaction aux différentes
interventions d'abord pour remercier
tous les intervenants de ce débat et ces
discussions générales
et dire que les différentes
interventions appel de ma part 3,3 aux
marques la première pour insister sur le
fait que en matière de fraude sociale la
lutte contre la fraude aux prestations
comme aux cotisations doit être mené de
front vous avez compris et madame
brouiller la les rappeler dans son
propos liminaire que le volume y compris
de recettes que nous devons nous pouvons
récupérer par la lutte contre la fraude
est bien plus important sur la fraude
aux prestations sur la fraude aux
cotisations individuelles mais il faut
aussi préciser qu'en matière de fraude
aux cotisations celles qui doivent nous
intéresser et celles sur lesquelles nous
devons nous concentrer sont les fraudes
organisées sont et frotte durable sont
les fraudes massives
et si évidemment chaque acte frauduleux
de tête condamné nous avons plus
d'intérêt pour ces fraudes organisées et
structurées que pour des fraudes ou
occasionnels et individuels qui même si
elles ne sont pas acceptables ne sont
pas arrangés ou en tout cas m sur un
plan d'un pied d'égalité
deuxième remarque pour dire à madame la
sénatrice lubin que je partage ce que
vous avez dit intégralement sur les
questions du du recours du taux de
recours je ne suis pas convaincu que le
débat sur la fraude d'une part et le
taux de recours de d'autre part doivent
être menées de manière concomitante ou
dans un même texte mais nous devons
travailler de manière beaucoup plus
efficace pour que celles et ceux qui ont
des droits
puissent les faire valoir et c'est
d'ailleurs parce que nous arriverons à
faire payer ceux qui peuvent payer en
termes de cotisations que nous pouvons
encore plus financer l'accès aux droits
de ceux qui en ont besoin et qui ont
légitimement accéderont troisième
remarque pour faire écho aux
interventions à l'hélium madame la
sénatrice pensée pardon madame mais je
suis obligé de corriger votre propos sur
au moins deux points
outre le fait que je ne partage pas
l'orientation générale vous avez indiqué
que la france avait perdu 700 mille
emplois en 2020 c'est totalement faux
nous avons perdu trois cent soixante
mille emplois c'est évidemment beaucoup
trop
nous craignons n'en perd 900 milles mais
je crois que quand on traverse une crise
économique il faut pas ajouter de la
dramaturgie ou du pessimisme
la scission
koné est par ailleurs l'insee a rendu
public ses estimations pour l'année 2020
sur le quatrième trimestre il se trouve
que de manière globale et donc en
moyenne et je ne renie rien des
disparités de situation le pouvoir
d'achat des ménages français a augmenté
de 0 6 % en 2020 derrière cette
évolution faible mais qui reste une
évolution surtout une année où on a vu
le pib reculé de 8 2% ce qui montre
l'efficacité des outils contracycliques
il y à l'hétérogénéité mais il n'y a pas
de diminution moyenne globale du pouvoir
d'achat des français
dernière chose deux dernières choses
pardonnez moi j'ai à écouter tous les
orateurs bien compris l'intérêt que
chacun d'entre vous avait polac sur la
question des documents d'identité en
couleur pour éviter la fraude
documentaire c'est un sujet sur lequel
nous travaillons sur lequel nous allons
pouvoir avancer compris de manière
réglementaire pour faire en sorte de
mieux prévenir et d'éviter la
falsification des documents
je précise par ailleurs que la
falsification des documents est souvent
un des piliers de la fraude organisée et
que bien souvent ce sont des usages et
honnête qui n'ont jamais rien demandé à
personne qui se voit usurper leur
identité qui se voit falsifié les
documents qui leur appartiennent pour
nourrir ensuite des réseaux de fraude
beaucoup plus structuré enfin tôt
dernier mot monsieur le président pour
demander à mesdames les sénatrices et
messieurs les sénateurs de bien vouloir
excuser mon départ dans une vingtaine de
minutes je dois me rendre à une réunion
d'arbitrage budgétaire à matignon je
serai remplacé au ban par olivier
grégoire secrétaire d'état mais je
préférais vous en informer avant que
vous voyez partir et bien passons à au
texte de la commission
article premier supprimé article de
supprimer mais un amendement de
rétablissement de l'article madame lubin
l'amendement de deux ont fait
contrairement est ce que monsieur le
rapporteur a indiqué dans sa
présentation de notre amendement de
casse celui ci ne porte pas sur la
demande d'un rapport mais vise bien
inscrire clairement l'objectif de lutte
contre le non recours dans les
conventions d'objectifs et de gestion
des organismes de la sécurité sociale
le non recours aux prestations est un
fléau bien plus répandue notamment en
matière d'accès aux soins que la fraude
sociale est l'intérêt pour ce sujet en
particulier
de notre majorité bien moins important
et aucunement à la hauteur du phénomène
pourtant la question du non recours
s'interrompt interroge sur l'effectivité
à pertinence de nos politiques publiques
de protection sociale ainsi que sur la
place accordée à l'usagé dans l'action
publique elle est en outre l'enjeu
fondamental de leur évaluation
c'est pourquoi nous sommes en droit
d'attendre de la commission des affaires
sociales du sénat qui a consacré à
l'initiative de la majorité sénatoriale
plusieurs rapports d'information sur la
fraude sociale qu'elle montre la même
ténacité à prendre à bras le corps
l'analyse des dépenses sociales ont
effectué à cause du non recours bon je
vais m'arrêter là on en a largement
parlé monsieur le ministre viennent
d'échanger avec nous voilà l'objet de
mon amendement
merci avis la commission sur le
rapporteur général
merci monsieur le président san avis
défavorable de la commission parce qu'il
me semble que dans l'école
il est prévu et je pense que d'ailleurs
dans la feuille de route de monsieur le
ministre il est bien précisé qu' il est
on lutte contre la fraude elle monsieur
louisiane le préciser tout à l'heure à
tous niveaux
ce soit aux cotisations aux
prescriptions prestations et dans les
causes je pense pas avoir effectivement
dans mon rapport plutôt plutôt
privilégier plus l'un ou l'autre de ces
domaines donc je pense que cet
amendement n'est pas à mon avis bien
situer d'ailleurs et donc c'est un avis
défavorable ou 6,6 à vis du gouvernement
et ses ministres
le retrait ou défavorable pour les
raisons que j'ai évoquées un instant
merci je vais mettre voit donc
l'amendement numéro 2 avec deux avis
défavorables qui pour madame lubin bruit
merci enfin je dis ça joue aussi
plurielle m'étonne mais bon qui est
contre eh bien il n'est pas adopté donc
l'article 2 reste supprimer l'article 3
est supprimé à l'article 4
deux amendements identiques de
suppression le ronge madame apourceau
poly
ah pardon merci merci monsieur le
président l'article 4 de cette
proposition de loi autorise l'accès aux
données des plates formes en ligne pour
contrôler les assurés sociaux au
détriment de notre point de vue les
libertés individuelles et du respect à
la vie privée
tout d'abord permettez moi de rappeler
que concernant l' usage des fichiers de
leurs croisements pour renforcer les
contrôles la cnil autorise je cite
l'automatisation des outils mais le
croisement des données les roquettes ne
doivent pas prendre la place de
l'intervention humaine dans le schéma de
décision d'autre part et comme l'a
indiqué ma collègue katia pourceaux poli
dans son intervention générale le
rapport de 2010 est du défenseur des
droits
constatait je cite que le développement
des contrôles depuis une dizaine
d'années et les pouvoirs nouveaux
conférer aux régimes de protection
sociale et à pôle emploi ne sont pas
sans soulever un certain nombre de
questions il ajouté en effet le
renforcement des contrôles entraîne un
accroissement du nombre de réclamations
car je cite la politique mise en oeuvre
en la matière marqué par certains excès
et quelques dérives est la source de
nombreuses atteintes aux droits des
usagers des services publics cibles
défenseur des droits qui le disaient
enfin leur seul recours croissant aux
data mining qui établit d'éventuels
corrélation signifiante est utilisable
entre les données peut elle aussi poser
des problèmes la définition des profils
ou situations à risque n'étant
évidemment pas neutre
la sécurité sociale disposent déjà des
outils pour lutter contre la fraude
mais on le voit tout n'est pas réglé
donc elle manque de moyens humains
ce sont eux qu'il faut renforcer la
proposition de loi visant à lutter
contre la fraude aux prestations
sociales ne cherche donc pas à améliorer
les contrôles de notre point de vue mais
plutôt à renforcer les conditions
d'accès aux prestations sociales ainsi
que la mise en place d'une cyber
surveillance c'est pourquoi nous
demandons la suppression de cet article
merci madame poncet mange le 16 merci
monsieur le président bien non seulement
je suis contre cet article mais je veux
par cet amendement dire autre chose
marquer mon étonnement pour ne pas dire
plus qu'on puisse proposer à l'encontre
des personnes bénéficiaires des
prestations sociales des mesures de
collecte et d'exploitation de leur
contenu librement accessibles sur
internet notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux et pas seulement du fait de la
complexité de la mise en oeuvre d'une
telle mesure parce que l'état de droit
mais parce que l'état de droit garantit
la protection des données à caractère
personnel
pour les écologistes il s'agit d'un pas
de plus vers la surveillance des
personnes sur internet
en collectant des contenus relatifs à la
vie privée
rappelons que la cnil mais je crois que
ça vient d'être faits s'étaient déjà
montrés critiques lorsque le
gouvernement avait suggéré un dispositif
similaire
ouvrant cette possibilité à
l'administration fiscale et douanière
lors du plf 2010 9 en s'interrogeant sur
son opportunité
en regard des garanties fondamentales
d'exercice des libertés publiques
aussi nous devrions nous soucier de la
conformité de cet article rg pdg
rappelle également que les publics
ciblés par les prestations sociales font
déjà l'objet de différents contrôles
pour le rsa par exemple des départements
des poids leurs propres contrôles en
plus de ceux de la caf et du pôle emploi
ces trois instances sont déjà bien dotée
de moyens de contrôle il convient de
rappeler qu'à leur rôle premier
d'accompagner de permettre l'accès aux
droits des personnes en difficulté ceux
qui s'opposent ou ce qui suppose au
préalable d'installer une relation de
confiance
les moyens de surveillance
généraliser renverse ce positionnement
et ce n'est pas acceptable
trop souvent l'obsession de la chasse
aux fraudeurs fait vivre aux personnes
concernées des calvaires administratif
aux conséquences quelquefois grave quand
elle n'a pas pour principal effet de
faire renoncer au droit
nous n'avons donc pas besoin d'un
dispositif de surveillance
supplémentaires qui se montre aurait
encore plus intrusive au mépris des
libertés individuelles du respect des
données de la vie privée des personnes
en situation de précarité cas pour 1 k
combien de personnes sur les sept
millions de personnes concernées par un
minima social seront ainsi malmenés nous
proposons donc par cet amendement
la suppression de cet article et pas
seulement de voter contre très bien avis
de la commission sur la portée générale
merci monsieur le président madame
monsieur madame poncet manche nous avons
dit en commission que cette
expérimentation est en cours pour la
fraude fiscale qui nous paraît
nécessaire d'attendre son retour
constate d'ailleurs un certain nombre de
difficultés juridiques et techniques qui
me font craindre qu'ils nous font
craindre des difficultés supplémentaires
pour justement l'expérimenté dans le
champ social
le champ social comporte pas une seule
administration et plusieurs organismes
donc la commission avait proposé un avis
de suppression sur dow favorable aussi à
vos deux amendements à vis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président le
grandement partage la position exprimée
par monsieur le rapporteur pour les
raisons qu'il a exprimée c'est à dire
qu'il a évoquée c'est à dire la
difficulté technique que poserait
l'application du texte tel qu'il est
proposé à cet instant le fait que nous
préférons aller au bout de
l'expérimentation dans le champ fiscal
avant d'élargir au champ social passe
comme si on apportera ainsi exprimé et
pour reprendre une partie des
amendements des arguments exprimés par
madame un morceau poli avis est
favorable
je dois dire que s'il n'y avait eu que
l'argumentaire de la seconde
intervenante madame je le répète je ne
partage pas du tout l'appréciation vous
avez du texte et je trouve même que la
définition et la description vous avez
fait du système de collecte de données
que vous avez vous même qualifié de
librement un rendu public par les
utilisateurs étaient trop caricatural
pour que nous puissions y souscrire mais
monsieur le rapporteur rappeler la
réalité des arbitres des arguments team
d'athènes qui nous amène à donner un
avis à mort très bien je vais donc
mettre aux voix ces deux amendements de
suppression de l'article iv avec deux
avis favorables commission et
gouvernement qui est pour et qui est
contre
[Musique]
les amendements sont adoptés
l'article 4 a été supprimé et donc
monsieur calvet votre amendement par
définition tombe
l'article 5 reste supprimer l'article ci
seraient supprimés après l'article 6
jana maintenance est rectifié madame
hébert
merci monsieur le président au sionisme
chers collègues
cet amendement vise à permettre aux
agents habilités par le président du
conseil départemental de pouvoir
échanger tous renseignements et ou
documents utiles à l'accomplissement des
missions de recherche et de constatation
des fraudes sociales je vous remercie et
avis de la commission c'est le
rapporteur général président c'est un
avis favorable parce qu'il me semble que
le rôle joué par les départements en
matière sociale rend cette extension a
tout à fait légitime et donc la
commission a émis un avis favorable à
vis du gouvernement monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président pour le coup
c'est un avis défavorable puisque le
code de l'action sociale et des familles
permet déjà de tels échanges entre les
conseils départementaux et les kiev avec
lesquels il partage des compétences de
contrôle pour la lutte contre la fraude
au rsa et il ne nous paraît pas utile
d'aller au delà ses bases mais pas
suffisante pour permettre des échanges
utiles dans le cadre des codaf en
particulier puisque les conseils
départementaux sont invités au cas par
cas et en fonction de l'ordre du jour
donc nous ne sommes pas favorable à
cette extension des prérogatives des
agents habilités par le des conseils
départementaux adamo l'est de manama
mais ce qu'on l'a vu dans dans le
rapport qu'on a commis avec carole
grandjean des très grandes difficultés
pour les départements et en plus à
suivre
les départements ne communiquent pas
entre eux si vous avez des comportements
limitrophes qui communiquent pas entre
eux sur ces données là donc moi je suis
très favorable à cette à cet amendement
ça facilitera grandement les choses se
calmer merci monsieur le président
monsieur michaud collège je suis
également très favorable à cet
amendement car effectivement il n'y a
rien de pire de vous que de voir les
abus et de ne pas pouvoir les
sanctionner et donc il est important que
à tous niveaux cela puisse effectuer
donc je mets aux voix le 7 rectifier
avec un avis favorable de la commission
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
et qui est contre
il est adopté le sceptre est supprimé à
l'article 8 un amendement 12
madame apourceau poly merci monsieur le
président alors l'article 8 e renforce
drastiquement les conditions d'accès à
la pl en subordonnant le versement de
l'aide à la transmission d'information
sur le logement
cette mesure complexifie inutilement la
procédure aux dépens des droits des
familles les plus précaires
je rappelle que l'omission constitué
constituée en 2010 9 70% des fraudes
détectées tandis que la production et
l'usagé de faux documents ont représenté
seulement 12 5% des fraudes qualifier
alors que le gouvernement a institué
pour les entreprises un droit à l'erreur
vous proposez d'inverser la charge de la
preuve pour les plus pauvres soumis à la
suspicion permanente de la tentative de
fraude
la réalité c'est qu'à force de renforcer
les contrôles pour soi disant plus de
justice vous êtes vous décourager les
honnêtes citoyens qui pourraient
bénéficier des aides sociales
aujourd'hui le non recours est renforcée
par les multiples démarches
administratives imposées pour soi disant
vérifier l'absence de fraude
c'est le constat du rapport du secours
catholique pour l'année 2018 qui
indiquaient une baisse de l'accès aux
allocations familiales de 5% et 83 % de
ces familles percevait les allocations
familiales en 2010 et seulement 78 % en
en imitant la lutte contre la fraude aux
prestations sociales des assurés sociaux
le test le texte stigmatise les plus
précaires et refuse de s'attaquer à la
fraude des entreprises dont le montant
est évalué par la cour des pompes à 25
milliards d'euros soit 25 fois plus que
le montant total de la fraude aux
prestations et 250 fois
elle de la fraude documentaire tel est
le sens de notre amendement de
suppression
je vous remercie avis de la commission
sur leurs attentes en général résidence
d'un avis défavorable de la cet
amendement de suppression
la commission a souhaité garder cet
article le 8
parce qu'il nous paraît intéressant
effectivement d'avoir effectivement des
précisions sur le logement qu'elles
l'aident ce rapport est donc les re
comme c'est d'ailleurs un article qui
est largement inspiré du rapport de la
cour des comptes qui avait souhaité
effectivement qu'elle avait souhaité
dans son rapport remis en septembre
dernier
donc c'est l'avis des fans des femmes
merci madame la ministre vont soir à vis
du gouvernement
bonsoir monsieur le président bonsoir
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs sur cet
article
8 l'avis du gouvernement sera favorable
parce que nous estimons que l'objectif
poursuivi est de sécuriser le versement
des aides au logement ce qui paraît
légitime et souhaitable toutefois
subordonné le versement de l'apl à la
transmission aux caves des principales
caractéristiques du logement auxquels
l'aide se rapporte susceptible
d'affecter sa valeur locative n'a pas
réellement d'intérêt en termes de
contrôle puisque cette valeur locative
n'est pas prise en compte dans le calcul
de l'aide au logement et ne peut donc
servir à détecter une fraude le
gouvernement ne peut donc revenir cette
mesure en l'état est donc favorable à
cet amendement de suppression je vous
remercie
très bien je vais mettre aux voix donc
cet amendement 12 avec un avis
défavorable du gouvernement faveur des
favorable de la commission favorable du
gouvernement qui est pour
euh oui alors attendez parce que allez
on reprend ses esprits pied pour voilà
non c'est pas grave je fais juste un peu
qui est contre
voilà merci est rejeté et je mets aux
voix l'article 8 qui est pour et qui est
contre
il est adopté
après l'article 8 l'amendement a vite
rectifié madame hébert
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre cet amendement prévoit un
changement de procédure d'attribution du
rsa compter du 1er janvier 2023 il ne
reviendrait plus au demandeur de fournir
les pièces nécessaires à l'instruction
de sa demande
mais l'administration à l'organisme de
récupérer les données le concernant
auprès de ses différents partenaires que
ça serait dur ça fout l'administration
fiscale tel est le sens de cette amende
mange
merci avis de la commission sur le
rapporteur général
le président cet amendement vise à
modifier la procédure d'attribution du
rsa
il reprend une disposition de
notre ancien collègue eric doligé
rapporté en 2016 d'ailleurs par corinne
imbert et donc on partage tout à fait en
commission l'attention de notre collègue
et je m'attache simplement sur des
possibilités qui existent déjà pour les
services en matière d'information pour
instruire les demandes au sein des caf
alors donc c'est pour cette raison que
notre réflexion est ouverte et que
peut-être d'ailleurs avec les évolutions
sur le rncps nous nous va nous
permettrait d'avancer et d'aller
peut-être un peu plus loin mais pour le
moment à ce stade c'est un avis de
sagesse que nous formulons à vis du
gouvernement madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président les
dispositions de l'article l100 14-12 du
code de la sécurité sociale qui sont
déjà applicables au rsa prévoit cette
possibilité pour les caisses de
récupérer directement les données
nécessaires à l'examen des demandes
auprès des autres administrations sans
qu'il soit utile de compléter le code de
l'action sociale en ce sens par ailleurs
des travaux sont engagés en ce moment
même pour que les caf et les caisse de
la msa puisse récupérer les informations
sur les ressources des demandeurs auprès
des différents opérateurs impliqués
cette réforme est rendue possible par la
disponibilité des données issues des
déclarations des employeurs et des
organismes qui versent les prestations
sociales la récupération automatique des
ressources des bénéficiaires se fera par
le biais du dispositif du drm du
dispositif de ressources mensuelles créé
par l'article 78 de la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2010 9 permettra de simplifier les
démarches des déclarants de stabiliser
les droits versés en limitant les indus
et rappelle faciliter le travail en
gestion pour les caisses et de favoriser
le juste eu recours à la prestation
votre amendement apparaît donc satisfait
endroit et le sera très prochainement en
pratique par une récupération désormais
automatique de certaines données
le gouvernement estime donc qu'il est
satisfait une demande de retrait et le
cas échéant ce sera défavorable je vous
remercie très bien madame boulet à vous
préférez attendre madame barul
maintenait oui monsieur le président je
maintiens l'amendement alors j'entends
bien ce que vient de dire madame la
ministre
satisfait endroit mais dans la vraie vie
pour l'instant ce n'est pas encore une
chaise il a mis en musique
donc je maintiens mon amendement oui
mais ces pressions moi je soutiens cette
disposition d'autant qu'elle provient
d'un rapport de 2016 c'est ça donc nous
sommes en 2000 en 2021 et en fait c'est
une application de dites le nous une
fois on remplace le déclaratif par un
échange et une aversion de 2 de la
production des éléments
donc si c'est déjà satisfait tant mieux
mais moi je crois qu'il faut voter cet
amendement on n'a que trop trop attendu
pour avoir cette application dudit cloud
une fois très bien donc
l'amendement 8 rectifier avec un avis de
sagesse de la commission et un avis
défavorable puisque non retirés du
gouvernement
je le mets aux voix qui est pour le 8
rectifier et inquiet contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté l'article 9
reste supprimait à l'article 10 une
prise de parole monsieur le rapporteur
général président je souhaite rappeler
que les dispositions de cet article que
cet article en modifier son nouvel elle
date de décembre 2020 nous en nous avons
en effet lors du dernier pdf et 16
codifier les dispositions de la loi de
financement de 2013 concernant la preuve
de l'existence pour les pensionnés
résidant à l'étranger ou dans certains
territoires ultramarins à l'occasion de
cette codification nous avions également
ouvert la possibilité de recourir à la
biométrie pour assurer le contrôle de
l'existence nous avions suivi cet
article au sein de la commission et le
rapporteur rené paul savary qui s'excuse
et qui m'a demandé est effectivement de
de défendre cette position avait proposé
un amendement modifiant sa rédaction
l'assemblée avait suivi par un confort
le rapporteur avait ainsi consulté sur
le sujet la cnav lâché sarkologies
puniet retraite pour nous mieux que pour
mieux comprendre la répartition des
rôles et le fonctionnement ce contrôle
de l'existence au sein des caisses la
rédaction issue de cette loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale de
2021 ne semble pas devoir être modifiés
aujourd'hui surtout quand je l'ait déjà
évoqué l'intention de l'auteur est tout
à fait satisfaite par les dispositions
qui sont issus de cette loi les
organismes conclut déjà les conventions
avec des homologues à l'étranger
permettant notamment des échanges
automatisés d'état civil la présente
rédaction ne contraint pas davantage les
procédures ni n'ouvre de facultés
nouvelle c'est donc pour notre part
notre de cesser de ne pas adopter cet
article haderer
je n'ai pas entendu vous venez de dire
que vous demandait la haute assemblée de
ne pas adopter l'article 10 c'est ça je
mets au voit donc l'article 10 qui n'est
pas tout cette par un amendement mais
avec une position défavorable de la
commission qui est pour l'article 10
qui est contre l'article 10
l'article 10 est adopté l'article 11 est
supprimé à l'article 12 une prise de
parole richard
si monsieur le président ce le président
madame un ministre mes chers collègues
j'interviens sur cet article 12 non pas
pour insister sur la demande d'un
rapport du parlement au gouvernement
mais pour dire toute l'importance de la
lutte contre les fraudes
transfrontalière en matière sociale en
fait je souhaitais intervenir sur
l'article 9 relatif aux échanges
d'informations entre organismes
européens de sécurité sociale la
commission des affaires sociales a jugé
bon de le supprimer
considérant qu'un règlement européen
portant coopération des systèmes de
sécurité sociale les prévoyait déjà le
prévoir dans la législation française ne
serait donc plus nécessaire selon la
commission à titre personnel je ne suis
pas sûr que cette coopération entre
organismes de européen de sécurité
sociale soit efficiente à 100% soit
efficace j'aimerais redire ici qu'en
zone frontalière la fraude sociale est
une réalité et qu'il convient de lutter
plus fermement contre son développement
or cette fraude est rendue possible
voire facilitée par l'absence ou
l'insuffisance des échanges de données
entre les pays et les organismes sociaux
même si le nombre progrès ont été faits
au fil des années depuis ce règlement
qui date déjà de beaucoup d'années une
meilleure coopération entre
administrations des pays concernés est
essentielle en attendant peut-être à
terme une harmonisation complète au
niveau européen de système de protection
la commission des affaires européennes
poursuit un travail est important en ce
sens et j'aime et j'ai moi-même
l'occasion en janvier 2020 de déposer
une proposition de résolution européenne
visant à lutter contre la fraude aux
prestations sociales et mettant l'accent
sur l'urgence de renforcer la
coopération entre les états celle ci a
été adopté par notre commission des
affaires européennes
en février 2001 ce qui montre que tout
n'est pas parfait en la matière c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire
je voudrais également dire un mot sur la
suppression par la commission de
l'article 11
celui ci proposait à l'origine qu'un
décret établisse une liste de pays dont
l'état civil serait présumés non fiables
si comme l'a dit la commission le
dispositif proposé risquait de poser des
problèmes diplomatiques ou politiques
sans vraiment résoudre le problème posé
je voudrais en qualité de président du
groupe d'amitié france afrique de
l'ouest confirmer ici les faiblesses
administratif que connaissent certains
pays de la zone en matière d'état civil
et d'alors confirmé également les
risques importants de fraude à
l'identité que cette situation génère il
est donc indispensable que la lutte
contre cette fraude passe par un
encouragement des états concernés à se
doter au plus vite des instruments
permettant la tenue d'un état civil
rigoureux et fiables
mes chers collègues socialement la faune
est plus acceptable surtout le contexte
difficile que nous connaissons en tant
que parlementaire nous devons nous est
attelé à éliminer toutes ses formes de
fraude qui réduisent par leur existence
même nos capacités budgétaires
je tiens donc ici monsieur le président
a félicité à remercier nathalie goulet
ses collègues pour ces variables
initiative allait elle est remerciée
alors je mets aux voix l'article 12
quand même quai pour piétons entre il
est adopté
après l'article 12 l'amendement 15
madame apourceau poly
si monsieur le président aujourd'hui la
sécurité sociale de dépose dispose
excusez-moi déjà de d'outils pour lutter
contre la fraude aux prestations
sociales
à l'inversé lmnp que considérablement de
moyens pour vérifier les fraudes au
paiement des cotisations sociales les
plans d'économie année après année on
dépecer les services de l'encaissement
des cotisations sociales
il faut donc un engagement politique
financier et humain contre la fraude aux
cotisations patronales estimé à 25
milliards d'euros par la cour des
comptes
par cohérence avec l'objet de la
proposition de loi qui mentionne la
fraude sociale
nous demandons que le gouvernement
réalise une eva
lui à sion récentes sur le montant de la
fraude patronale aux cotisations
sociales et surtout formule des
recommandations pour lutter contre ce
type de fraude
l'avis défavorable de la commission des
affaires sociales démontre bien que vous
refusez de vous attaquer au coeur du
problème et préférait pointer du doigt
les plus pauvres de ce pays
merci merci à lui la commission monsieur
le rapporteur général à monsieur le
président je conteste tout à fait les
conclusions de madame apourceau poly je
crois que on stigmatise pas plus les
pauvres que que les entreprises dans
cette affaire un tel rapport ne nous
sommes pas présentés d'utilité
particulière d'état l'urssaf lutte déjà
contre la fraude aux cotisations même si
en la matière est tout à l'heure
monsieur le ministre nous le rappeler il
ya des techniques de plus en plus
astucieuse qui apparaissent
régulièrement
donc je pense que le rapport sur les
fraudes transfrontalière que nous venons
de voter l'article 12 peut d'ailleurs
mettre en lumière certaines de ces
techniques et des moyens d'y remédier et
donc pour l'heure c'est un avis
défavorable de la commission à vis du
gouvernement madame la ministre
le président pour des raisons assez
similaire à celle énoncée à l'instant
par le rapporteur l'agît du gouvernement
sera aussi défavorable sur cette demande
de rapport d'abord et avant tout on
partage évidemment ce souci de de
disposer de plus d'informations pour
mieux évaluer la réalité de la fraude
sociale sous toutes ses formes
mais le montant du manque à gagner
résultant pour la sécurité sociale les
cotisations éludée par les employeurs
fait d'ailleurs et vous le savez bien
l'objet d'évaluations périodiques en
2019 le montant de ce préjudice pour
information et est ainsi évalué à un
montant compris entre 6 et 8 milliards 8
4 milliards d'euros soit 2
2 à 2 7 % des cotisations dues
évidemment de nouvelles estimations de
la fraude seront réalisés par la qos et
par la ccmsa dans le cadre du plan de
fraude lancées en janvier cet effort
renouvelé pour disposer de chiffres
fiables sur la fraude sociale sous
toutes ses formes permettra un meilleur
maillage des opérations de contrôle et
un pilotage de fait plus performante la
lutte contre la fraude et donnera lé
bien entendu lieu à des publications
c'est pourquoi pour le gouvernement la
publication d'un rapport ne paraît pas
nécessaire c'est donc un avis
défavorable je vous remercie très bien
donc sur l'amendement 15 avec deux avis
défavorables qui est pour et qui est
contre
il est rejeté l'article 13 et supprimer
l'article 14 un amendement 13 madame
apourceau poly ou madame cohen
madame kane cycle 14 rend obligatoire la
création d'un compte bancaire en france
pour obtenir le versement des
prestations sociales
cette contraintes administratives
inutiles et stigmatisante pour les
personnes étrangères qui devront payer
les frais d'ouverture et de gestion d'un
compte bancaire pour bénéficier de
l'aide sociale cette disposition est
d'autant plus inacceptable que
s'agissant des entreprises
le gouvernement ne demande pas pour
verser l'aide du fonds de solidarité de
disposer d'un compte bancaire en france
le fonds de solidarité pour prévenu
prévenir la cessation d'activité des
entreprises touchées par les
conséquences économiques du covin
prévoit que je cite tous les comptes
domiciliés dans un établissement
bancaire en france ou à l'étranger sont
acceptées par le formulaire l'article 14
a donc créé une inégalité de situation
entre les entreprises et les
bénéficiaires des aides sociales puisque
les premiers n'ont pas l'obligation de
disposer d'un compte bancaire financier
en france pour toucher l'aide financière
de l'état
pour toutes ces raisons nous demandons
la suppression de cet article je vous
remercie
merci
avis de la commission sur important
général monsieur le président et
d'écouté il n'y a aucune raison
objective pour versé sur un compte non
européen à une prestation lier une
condition de résidence en france
au demeurant le dispositif serait encore
plus efficace si l'obligation de
versements se limiter aux comptes
français mais là cela conviendrait au
droit européen au droit communautaire
comme le gouvernement nous le confirmera
sans doute donc la commission a souhaité
conserver cet article est émis un avis
défavorable à sa suppression par le
groupe crc avait du gouvernement madame
la ministre
merci monsieur le président c'est un
avis favorable pour le gouvernement une
seule seul une obligation de versement
sur un compte français permettrait de
contrôler l'identité des titulaires de
comptes bancaires
le droit européen qui interdit de
traiter différemment les établissements
bancaires établies dans l'union combiné
à l'absence d'outils de type ficoba au
niveau européen
j donc en pratique la mesure proposée de
son intérêt en termes de contrôle nous
sommes donc favorable à cet amendement
de suppression je vous remercie
très bien je vais donc mettre aux voix
l'amendement de 13 avec un avis
défavorable de la commission favorable
du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
il est rejeté et donc l'article 14 je le
mets aux voix qui votent pour l'article
14 qui est pour les mêmes j'imagine qui
est contre il est adopté
après l'article 14 un amendement 9
rectifié madame r merci monsieur prison
de la ministre cet amendement propose
d'étendre la flagrance sociale à tout
type de fraude sociale matière fiscale
cet outil de la flagrance permet aux
agents des impôts dresser un procès
verbal qui emporte des effets tels que
des mesures conservatoires en cas de
constatation fait frauduleux rapide et
efficace la flagrance a fait ses preuves
dans la lutte contre la fraude fiscale
cet amendement crée donc la flagrance
sociale un outil à disposition des
inspecteurs de recouvrement fin de
percevoir des prestations sociales
obtenues frauduleusement ville la
commission se lamente un jeune homme la
commission trouvé ce dispositif plutôt
intéressant on aimerait quand même avoir
l'avis du gouvernement sur le fond en ce
qui concerne la satire l'instauration
d'une telle procédure de flagrance
néanmoins le dispositif précis comporte
quelques défauts et c'est pour la raison
pour lesquelles l'avis du gouvernement
nous est précieux nous serait précieux
voilà du gouvernement madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président il
n'apparaît pas au gouvernement
souhaitable d'étendre le dispositif de
flagrance à tous types de fraudes
commises en matière sociale d'abord les
fraudes aux prestations sont le fait de
particuliers est généralement et non
d'entreprise pas nécessaire de fait
d'établir un procès verbal pour les
constater il suffit comme vous
l'imaginez pour le contrôleur de caisse
de montrer que l'assuré a sciemment
minorer le montant de ses revenus
pour bénéficier d'une prestation sous
conditions de ressources par exemple
deuxièmement le recouvrement des indus
frauduleux se heurte très souvent bien
plus à l'insolvabilité de l'assuré
qu'est la difficulté de saisir des biens
comme c'est le cas pour une entreprise
qui fraude aux cotisations et organise
houas organiserait son insolvabilité la
procédure n'apparaît donc pas adapté aux
fraudes sociales autres que celles
correspondant à la dissimulation
d'activité ou d'emplois salariés
elle pourrait avoir ensuite un effet
disproportionné par rapport au but
recherché
pour ces raisons le gouvernement n'est
pas favorable à cet amendement
sur le coup la commission jeu je pense
que on a émis un avis de sagesse le seul
président parfait donc amendement 9 a
vite de la commission défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour et qui est
contre
[Musique]
il est adopté à l'article 15
l'amendement 18 monsieur le rapporteur
général et dakhla c'est une amendements
rédactionnels correction d'une erreur je
le faisais maintenant c'est un avis
favorable bien je me vois le 18 avec
deux amis enfin c'est l'amendement de la
commission avec un avis for a bigger
bang et pour qui est contre il est
adopté l'amendement 5 rectifié terme
semaine en ville merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre
cet amendement vise tout simplement à
préciser la rédaction d'un cycle 15 afin
de permettre à un organisme de
protection sociale de déclencher donc
cette procédure de contrôle
complémentaire en présentiel
même après l'inscription au registre
après inscription donc de que le
registre a été un vide que l'inscription
au registre a été validée donc les
contrôles peuvent être réalisées lors de
l'inscription mais aussi après
inscription et lors de la validation
d'inscription très bien avis de la
commission sur un portage général sur le
sur le président la rédaction retenue
satisfait à mon sens l'intention de
monsieur mais non ville bien évidemment
l'entretien doit pouvoir être demandés à
tout moment c'est le sens de la
possibilité présenté comme subsidiaire
un texte réglementaire doit d'ailleurs
précisé sa mise en oeuvre
donc c'est plutôt une demande de retrait
sinon défavorable à vis du gouvernement
rectifiez terre autant pour moi merci
monsieur le président ici c'est ces
dispositions conflit confère déjà les
agents chargés du contrôle agréé
assermenté le soin de procéder à toute
vérification enquête administrative
concernant l'attribution des prestations
le respect des conditions de résidence
de ressources etc
ça implique la possibilité de convoquer
physiquement la personne objet du
contrôle les textes existants prévoit
déjà la possibilité de convoquer un
assuré dans le cadre de contrôles
l'objectif visé par votre amendement
nous sommes donc par conséquent
satisfait c'est donc un avis amendement
satisfait demande de retrait et le cas
échéant défavorable je vous remercie
monsieur béland ville merci je mets donc
qu'aux voix l'article 15 qui est pour et
qui est contre
il est adopté l'article 16 est supprimé
je mets au voile article 17 n'est pas
demande manqué pour qui est contre
il est adopté à l'article 18 nous avons
deux amendements identiques de
suppression d'abord madame cohen pour le
14 merci monsieur le président l'article
18 habilite les agents de contrôle des
organismes de sécurité sociale et de
l'inspection du travail à mener des
enquêtes judiciaires
il n'est pas acceptable de transférer la
mission des services d' enquête
judiciaire sous le prétexte qu'ils
seraient surchargé il faut au contraire
renforcer les moyens de ses services
d'autant que cette faculté déjà reconnu
pour la lutte contre le travail illégal
à l'inspection du travail à pôle emploi
et aux urssaf étendre encore cette
habilitation aux fraudes des prestations
sociales revient à faire supporter une
partie du coût des enquêtes aux
organismes de protection sociale et
surtout des engage l'état en fait de ses
responsabilités en matière fiscale
la création de la procédure judiciaire
denquête fiscale s'est accompagné par la
création de la brigade nationale de
répression de la délinquance fiscale
composée d'officiers de police
judiciaire et d'agents des services
fiscaux
l'article 18 prévoit de confier aux
agents de contrôle de la sécurité
sociale et de l'inspection du travail
une mission qui nécessiterait la
création d'un corps distincts avec des
personnels formés spécifiquement à la
procédure pénale en l'absence de ses
moyens humains et financiers et de cette
formation
vous allez donc mes chers collègues
détériorer la lutte contre la fraude que
vous souhaitez pourtant renforcée pour
toutes ces raisons nous demandons donc
la suppression de cet article jour merci
merci le 17 madame pensée mange
oui donc beaucoup de choses ont été
dites je vais raccourcir en fait
en fait cette mesure fait écho à une
disposition appliquée donc aux services
fiscaux hors jeu je souhaite quand même
pointé qu'il existe de larges
différences de logique entre les
administrations sociales et fiscales
là encore cela accompagne un changement
de philosophie de posture par rapport
aux missions premières des organismes de
sécurité sociale
d'autant que je pense cette disposition
sera très difficile sur le plan
opérationnel en regard aussi de ce qui
vient d'être dit et du peu d'impact
qu'elle produira donc nous voterons
compte
merci enfin nouveau pour la mode on
avait compris enfin pour la bruit pour
la maman avis du rapporteur général
monsieur monsieur le président on va
écouter on a déjà évoqué en commission
les grandes réserves que nous avions sur
cet article parce que ça supposerait
pour des raisons opérationnelles
formation longue et appropriée
évidemment des agents de contrôle pour
un bénéfice qui reste semble-t-il
difficile à apprécier
compte tenu que les agents effectivement
de contrôle déjà la possibilité
effective en de poursuivre sur un plan
judiciaire
donc par une coopération qui existe et
qui me semble qu'il nous semble
satisfaisante sur le plan opérationnel
actuellement de coopération entre la
police et puis les agents de contrôle
des organismes sociaux
donc pour toutes ces raisons sommes
favorable à ces amendements de
suppression avait du gouvernement madame
la ministre qui monsieur le président
pour les strictement les mêmes raisons
qu'énoncé par monsieur le rapporteur
le gouvernement est favorable à ces
amendements de suppression je remercie
très bien tu le mets au voit donc ses
deux amendements du passion avec 2 à vif
avoir un gouvernement et commission qui
est pour
qui est pour les amendements bien sûr
oui bah oui oui on vote les amendements
votre pas les articles d'accord qui est
contre ils sont adoptés et l'article 18
et donc supprimer l'article 19 reste
supprimer l'article 20 également je mets
au voile article 21 sur lequel il n'ya
pas d'amendement qui est pour et qui est
contre
[Musique]
il est adopté je mets ouvre à l'article
22 sur lequel n'ya pas d'amendement qui
est pour et qui est contre
[Musique]
il est adopté l'article 23 reste
supprimée de même que le 24 je mets
ouvre à l'article 25 sur lequel n'ya pas
d'amendement qui est pour et qui est
contre
[Musique]
il est adopté j'ai ensuite l'amendement
numéro quatre sur l'intitulé du de la
proposition de loi en en numéro 4 adam
l'ubs à la question de la fraude sociale
suscite beaucoup de fantasmes
au point d'avoir été associé d'ailleurs
à une cause du trou de la sécu dans la
tête de certains et en tant que sujet
sensible pour l'opinion publique il
n'est pas exempte d'instrumentalisation
politique pour lutter contre ces
fantasmes il convient de sortir du flou
de l'ambiguïté parfois volontairement
entretenue le discours récurrent sur la
fraude sociale le temps d'un effet à
faire croire que notre système est en
lui-même fraudogène et à alimenter la
suspicion à l'égard de leurs
bénéficiaires légitimes
or nous sommes tous bénéficiaires à un
moment de notre vie à un degré ou à un
autre de prestations sociales
si la lutte contre la fraude
intentionnel est légitime elle se doit
d'être juste c'est-à-dire outre la
nécessité de sa compagne et du même
volontarisme en matière d'accès au droit
et de lutte contre le non recours aux
prestations sociales
viser tous les types de fraudes en
premier lieu la fraude fiscale qui est
bien supérieur en termes de montant à la
fraude sociale
arrêtez de faire croire que la fraude
aux prestations et plus importante que
celle aux cotisations quand la vérité
est inverse les entreprises et
professionnels fraude de plus que les
particuliers en conséquence ne pas aller
au plus facile en visant prioritairement
les particuliers sortir de l' amalgame
du vocable fraude sociale les situations
individuelles qui relève de la non
intentionnalité et qui sont dus
essentiellement à la complexité
administrative du système de protection
sociale d'avec les fraudes
intentionnelle organisée au premier rang
desquelles celle des réseaux
professionnels qui relèvent elles de la
délinquance merci à vis de la commission
sous la porte en général oui vous pouvez
écouter ce un avis défavorable sur
président parce qu'il n'ya pas que des
fraudes organisées il ya aussi des
fraudes individuel donc je crois que
l'appréciation fraude sociale me paraît
beaucoup plus générique est générale et
donc la précision souhaitais me paraît
pas souhaitable disent défavorables à
vis du gouvernement madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président l'intitulé
de la proposition de loi relève de la
volonté de ses auteurs et ça n'est pas
moi qui ai tant de respect pour nos
chambres et qui a été parlementaire
trois ans et demi qui viendraient me
glisser dans ce débat c'est donc un
grand habit de sagesse pour le
gouvernement joue remercie très bien bon
jeu mais l'amendement quatre voies avec
un avis défavorable de la commission
sagesse du gouvernement qui est pour et
qui est contre
[Musique]
il est rejeté je vais mettre on voit
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi y at
il des demandes d'explication de votre
madame boulet à damas pour se polit
madame boulet oui mais ce président mais
la ministre ce rapporteur général je
voudrais remercier le rapporteur
gouvernement et mes collègues prêt à
voter la quasi-totalité des des articles
qui restaient en discussion dire que
c'est un pas pour pour préparer le plfss
alors je ne sais pas s'il y aura une
niche à l'assemblée nationale mais il ya
au moins plusieurs dispositions j'étais
un peu surprise d'ailleurs que nos
collègues de l'opposition sénatoriale
votre pas l'article 22 sur les
entreprises éphémère parce que pour le
coup c'est là qu'on a les patrons voyous
de la fraude aux cotisations de la
fraude aux prestations c'est c'est un
sujet qui est vraiment important ces
entreprises éphémère qui en plus créé de
la distorsion de concurrence sur nos
territoires
donc je crois - la ministre que sur les
sujets de la fraude transfrontalière
comme on l'a déjà fait remarquer
plusieurs reprises votre collègue nous
avait annoncé lors du plfss un travail
du claisse je crois qu'on l'attend
encore
donc nous pavon chemin vers le plfss
plus le travail que le ministre du stop
et le gouvernement a lancé sur ce sujet
devrait nous permettre cette fois ci
d'avoir un vrai un vrai dispositif
contre la fraude sociale encore une fois
c'est pas une fraude de pauvres c'est
pas une fraude qui stigmatise et en ce
qui concerne la fraude aux cotisations
nous y sommes évidemment tout aussi
attentif
donc évidemment le groupe de l'union
centriste qui a déposé cette proposition
dans cette niche et est très favorable à
cette proposition
évidemment que nous allons évidemment
voté en l'état c'est madame à pour ce
volet
merci monsieur le président écoute et
notre groupe pense qu'en pleine pandémie
ce n'était pas cette proposition de loi
n'était pas la priorité
d'autant qu'il y à beaucoup d'inquiétude
de désespérance chez nos concitoyens ce
soit au niveau sanitaire ou sociale et
donc nous pensons que ce n'était pas le
moment d'aller taper
évidemment une fois de plus sur les plus
pauvres alors nous l'avons dit nous
sommes évidemment contre les fraudes
ça va de soi mais en commission des
affaires sociales l'ensemble des groupes
ont dénoncé un texte inaboutie 25
articles initialement pour tomber à 10
et donc nous avons pour notre part
regretté compris qu'il n'y ait pas
d'audition des organisations syndicales
des salariés et qu'il n'y ait pas les
services de l'inspection générale qui
soit auditionné alors nous l'avons dit
tout au long de ce texte avec ma
collègue laurence cohen
il y as pour nous deux poids deux
mesures puisque il n'y a aucune
comparaison il faut bien se le dire
entre fraude sociale aux prestations
sociales qui je le rappelle sont d'un
milliard 2 et avec la lutte contre la
fraude fiscale et patronales qu'il nous
faudrait mener de front alors parce que
selon l' agence centrale des organismes
de sécurité sociale
l'acoss en 2018
la fraude patronale était estimée entre
6 et 8 milliards et 8,4 milliards
d'euros soit huit fois plus que la
fraude aux prestations sociales pour
toutes ces raisons nous allons voter
contre cette proposition de loin parce
que nous le disons une fois de plus
finalement il y à vraiment deux poids
deux mesures je vous remercie
merci je mets aux voix
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi dans
la commission a rédigé ainsi l'intitulé
proposition de loi tendant à appliquer
diverses mesures urgentes pour lutter
contre les fraudes sociales qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient elle est adoptée
[Musique]